first session of iraq's newly elected
parliament began with the ceremony but
quickly turned it angry its first job
was picking a speaker
two competing shia blocks the southwest
movement and an iranian-backed coalition
each claimed to have a parliamentary
majority at one point the debate became
so heated that the assembly's temporary
leader mahmoud al-mashadhani had to
leave the chamber to seek medical
attention eventually
the former speaker muhammad al-halbosi
was re-elected along with deputy
speakers from the southwest movement and
the kurdistan democratic party
but the day's events showed that little
has changed
since last october's elections
the way political blocs enter the
parliament with their old rivalries and
ideologies and practices in mind
indicates a lack of harmony and reflects
a hostile message conveyed across
under iraq's post-saddam hussein
constitution the parliament now has 30
days to elect the country's new
president who will then ask the
assembly's largest block to form a
government the speaker says he wants to
do all this in just half that time but
choosing a prime minister will be
difficult because shia cleric mukta the
sodar and the iranian-backed parties
have such different agendas
and sunday's drama points toward an even
more difficult time when it comes to
picking a cabinet
the losing parties are expected to take
legal actions at the supreme court again
and deploy their supporters to the
streets but that will not change
anything
iraqis have waited for long to see their
new house of representatives in session
but some fear that real change may once
again be derailed by sectarian
differences
some iraqis see the newly elected
parliament as a chance to end corruption
and begin a new era
but in a landscape market by uncertainty
and political rivalry
it is not clear whether this new
legislature
is able or willing
to address those concerns
mahmoud